[Musique]
salut
bien nous continuons sur notre débat sur
alimentation et agriculture donc après
avoir entendu à la fois nos propositions
la voix des producteurs avec avec
christiane lambert mais aussi au delà de
la voix des producteurs une vraie vision
pour l'agriculture et puis de deux
belles perspectives pardon pour ce beau
métier
donc maintenant on va passer à la grande
distribution avec bon quelqu'un qui est
incontournable dans la grande
distribution avec michel edouard leclerc
on a pas dit beaucoup de mal la grande
distribution jusque là michel edouard
c'est tous retenu
on va dire on va pas faire ça tous qu'il
est pas là mais c'est important que l'on
puisse avoir cette discussion parce qu
on l'évoquait tout à l'heure 75 % de ce
que nous avons dans nos assiettes passe
par la grande distribution
et aujourd'hui il y a à la fois on l'a
évoqué dans nos propositions la
nécessité d'avoir une alimentation saine
de qualité accessible à tous
c'est un enjeu qui est déterminant pour
le monde agricole est tout simplement
pour notre notre pays et aussi de
respecter l'acte de production celui de
ces gens qui comme le disait laurent
tout à l'heure qui se lèvent tôt
chaque jour et qui font ce métier avec
avec d'action avec conviction avec
engagement avec aussi souvent d
endettement très élevé et qui ont besoin
d'avoir une perspective parce que
l'agriculture que ce soit pour des
éleveurs ou en grandes cultures ou en
fruits et légumes on n'appuie pas sur un
bouton la chaîne se met en route sur un
autre bouton elle s'arrête c'est c'est
de l'investissement qui est long c'est
c'est beaucoup d'engagement c'est
beaucoup de savoir faire et tout cela
mérite d'être respectée au meilleur au
meilleur niveau
alors ce que ce que je vous propose je
te laisser la parole tout de suite j'ai
les doigts c'est pas la peine de mettre
le masque tout de suite c'est moi qui
vais le mettre dans un instant c'est
peut-être de réagir sur les nos
différentes propositions
et puis ensuite au bout de bon si cette
minute mais tu es comme beaucoup d'entre
nous assez bavard donc on va faire
attention que ça dépasse pas trop et
ensuite d'avoir un débat parce que c'est
c'est ce que tu souhaites est ce que tu
fais souvent très bien donc on aura
l'occasion d'échanger avec nos
parlementaires qui ont préparé ce débat
dont je te laisse peut être réagir
d'abord sur nos propositions face caméra
et puis c'est bon ça marche eh bien
merci merci christian j'ai toujours
plaisir de retrouver
il faut savoir que christian et moi on a
eu un débat toujours passionné sur
l'agriculture mais quand tu as tu m'a
téléphoné pour venir et ici j'ai répondu
tout de suite favorablement parce que tu
incarnes pour moi d'abord une politique
ouverte
on sait on a pu se mettre des beignes on
a pu discuter se contredire mais on se
respecte et tu véhicule beaucoup le
respect des personnes
donc j'ai toujours aimé débattre avec
toi et avancer avec toi et merci aussi à
valérie avec qui on a préparé cette
intervention et merci christiane aussi
que tu n'es pas trop dit de mal de moi
mais je voudrais te dire que je t'aime
tu es une belle personne et que c'est
doit pas être facile non plus à haut
niveau où tu es de pouvoir réguler déjà
cette société très masculine aussi qui
est la nôtre dans la distribution comme
dans la dans l'agriculture
en tout cas donc pour essayer de
d'enrichir les réflexions j'ai trouvé
que dans vos propositions
il y avait des axes forts et il ya deux
ou trois choses dont j'aimerais bien que
qu'on discute ensemble donc moi je monte
d'observatoire c'est des plus jeunes que
moi mais c'est quand même
l'arriéré qu'on a on a changé de monde
mais quand même on colporte notre
histoire et puis les agriculteurs comme
d'ailleurs les distributeurs qui ont
investi ils sont encore en phase de
remboursement
et donc quand on leur dit de changer de
modèle quand on leur dit de changer de
concept
faut pas déconner c'est c'est le temps
de l'entreprise le temps de
l'exploitation n'est pas le temps des
injonctions ni le temps des ong ni même
le temps du débat enfin c'est évident
que dans l'action il on a fait des choix
et autant on doit accepter les critiques
les autocritiques distributeurs
agriculteurs rapport à l'environnement
rapports sociaux autant il faut faire
avec les hommes et aussi avec les
engagements et avec le souci des
engagements qu'ils ont pris
donc je crois que l'agriculture
française et l'agroalimentaire français
est un vecteur fort de l'image de la
france et va le rester
parce que d'abord nous sommes beaucoup
d'acteurs à vouloir le faire et c'est
bien de la part des républicains de le
mettre dans l'axé central d'une
politique offensive de en tout cas pour
pour une place retrouvez ou défendu de
la france à l'international
on a beau dire que les bretons dont je
suis ont tendance à toujours ramasser
tous les débats en disant embêtant sur
l'export et en mettant sur le marché
mondial l'intérêt à agir
je crois que aujourd'hui
la crise que nous vivons la crise
sanitaire renforce renforce le besoin
d'une politique alimentaire de bon
niveau d'excellence et qu'elle soit et
c'est là où j'ai ma partie accessible au
plus grand nombre pour assurer aussi les
débouchés comme sinon on fait du bio
pour les bobos et ont fait pas une
politique alimentaire pour l'ensemble
des français
donc moi je je je retiens dans gros
comme ça rapidement pour lancer le débat
je pense qu'il faut éviter effectivement
les sur transposition sur norme en
france
c'est bien de vouloir être pionnier sur
les normes mais quand on se tire une
balle dans le pied
c'est difficile de courir donc je le
fais un peu à la louche comme ça mais je
vous rejoins complètement sur le fait
que bien faire ça veut pas dire se
plomber ensuite
la politique de discernement à l'égard
des petits producteurs
même si ce mode n'est pas beautiful
épique il faut espérer que le petit
puisse grandir
je suis assez d'accord que ce soit par
la loi par les pratiques par les accords
il faut travailler le discernement dans
ce qu'on réclame c'est évident que dans
le rapport du faible au fort hood dans
le rapport de de gestion de
référencement d'achat il faut pas que la
loi soit forcément protectrice mais
qu'elle soit différenciée dans les
applications c'est pas la même chose de
négocier avec nestlé et de négocier avec
un producteur derrière chez moi
ensuite le contrôle le renforcement des
contrôles
la recherche de plus grande transparence
la politique du gendarme bon c'est pas à
moi qui suis plutôt libertaire de
m'opposer à ce qui est le rôle de l'état
au le rôle du législateur
après moi j'ai l'impression quand même
qu'aujourd'hui tout l'arsenal
enfin la limite on est presque la rda
aujourd'hui tous les centrales d'achat
sont perquisitionnées les compteurs sont
relevés
vendredi dernier il était chez tout le
monde que ce soit chez les fournisseurs
ou chez les distributeurs
il faut pas que la transparence devient
une invocation pour ceux qui n'ont pas
de politique concurrence autre politique
agricole en fait aujourd'hui
l'administration a tout ce qu'il faut
pour connaître les marges
et puis s'il n'y avait pas les
perquisitions et et les demandes de
renseignements il ya aussi
l'observatoire des prix et des marges
qui existe qui va d'ailleurs sortir
avant l'été
bon on peut je pense qu'on peut
renforcer les politiques pénales etc
mais franchement ça être pas la solution
et moi je pense que je trouve donc c'est
pas le volet que je vais soutenir le
plus cher christian et fut un temps où
c'était pas le volet que tu voulais
soutenir le plus d'ailleurs quand tu
étais un peu plus voilà envier en
comprendre la sagesse
ok après je pense que moi je pense qu'il
faut rester très pragmatique et il faut
qu'une politique soit lisible
aujourd'hui on veut tous traités par la
loi alors on voit l'intérêt des lobbies
ça peut être la distribution on est
concurrent entre distributeurs un livecd
elle défend pas les mêmes dispositions
que biocoop etc
on peut penser essayer de réguler par la
loi et je ne suis pas un ultralibéral et
je suis d'accord que sur beaucoup de
marchés il faut plus de régulation mais
elle peut venir aussi bien de la loi que
d'accord de secteur un petit peu comme
dole le domaine social
c'est le patron de la cfdt récemment qui
rappelait quand même l'intérêt en
allemagne des accords de branche
alors qu'en france on essaie de tout
faire passer par le cône normatif qu'on
dénonce par ailleurs
donc là je pense que il ya un vrai
déficit dans dans la pratique de la
relation industrie commerce et dans la
politique que des débouchés agricole
d'accord sectoriel il ya un vrai déficit
de dialogue interprofessionnel et pour
le coup vous savez bien les
interprofessions elles vont pas jusqu'au
bout ou en tout cas ne fonctionne pas
jusqu'au bout donc plutôt que deux en
tout cas si la loi fixe le cadre elle
devrait favoriser aujourd'hui
coût plus la tentative de résolution des
problèmes que plutôt que des dictées ce
par quoi il devrait être résolu ça
suppose qu'il s'est parlé très français
mais bon alors ça va ok donc je suis
très étonné d'abord de notre temps tu
avais initiés beaucoup de rencontres
interprofessionnelles est au fond un
ministre de l'agriculture aujourd'hui un
premier ministre en bon politique
devrait d'abord pouvoir nommer le
problème le dissocier du court terme ou
du structurel et du long terme
sur le court terme ben la loi même
aujourd'hui autorisent des accords
interprofessionnels surtout quand il ya
des menaces sociales à la clé et qui a
crise
il suffit de définir la crise nommé la
crise personne ne viendra de la
commission européenne ou de l'autorité
de la concurrence venir contester bon
peut-être même après coup mais venir
contester la tentative de résolution à
l'amiable et après discussions entre des
impôts avec les trois grandes parties à
l'achat pour pour les produits agricoles
donc on voit bien en plus dans cette
période de qu'ovide là où on a tout le
monde a l'air de trouver de l'argent
magique et de la peau ne s'embarrasse
plus de précautions pour pour finalement
nous réunir sur des problèmes sociaux
sur les problèmes environnementaux
moi je veux je pense qu'aujourd'hui
l'urgence c'est de dire sur le lait sur
le net tel catégorique sur la viande sur
la viande rouge sur la vie races à
viande de définir le problème là tout de
suite de le traiter de le traiter en
considération économique de traiter en
considération et financière mais le
traité aussi en considération sociale ya
pas de volet social suffisamment clair
pour la politique agricole
c'est clair qu'aujourd'hui par exemple
nous avions le choix
leclerc carrefour intermarché pendant la
crise du crédit te proposer à des
salariés d'être en chômage partiel ou
d'être affecté à un poste sous prétexte
que les exploitants ce sont des libéraux
enfin sont des entrepreneurs
on n'aborde pas ce sujet là
pourquoi ne pas l'aborder il ya pas de
fausse pudeur quand les types vont aller
à la casse vaut mieux régler les
problèmes très concrètement s'il veut
dire les nommer mettre les gens autour
de la table
regardez qui peut les résoudre et puis
si c'est une solution de transitoire et
bien on l'a où on l'a montrent l epa
structurantes
elle est transitoire elle vaut pour un
an pour deux ans et on l'a fait adouber
comme il faut et puis on revient on
cherche à remettre le curseur sur le
long terme sur une régulation dans ses
démarches et donc je réponds pas à tous
le je vais répondre à vos questions mais
en tout cas je voudrais que vous sachiez
que à titre personnel et avec mes
collègues des centres leclerc mais je
crois aussi
sans être le porte parole de la grande
distribution parler aussi bien au nom de
dieu aux banques de dominique schelcher
nous sommes disponibles aujourd'hui pour
un tel dialogue
deuxièmement même si la période des
négos fait apparaître plus de polémiques
et c'est sur le fond si vous regardez
nos pubs à la télé depuis deux ans et
même plus qui des signes on est tous
logés à compatibles on est tous ga
aujourd'hui porter d'accord et que ce
soit pour les alliances locales le
retour aux territoires l'aide ou le
soutien à plus petit que nous que ce
soit sur les labels que ce soit les
indications d'origine que vous rendez
compte en même pas deux ans l'asca
marque qui est la société qui fabrique
les marques de distributeur pour leclerc
a changé 4000 emballages pour imposer le
nutrisse corps ça n'a pas fait la
révolution
on l'a fait ça attirait les recettes
vers le meilleur moins de sel moins de
sucre etc
on est tous sur la même longueur d'onde
ce qu'on va bien faire va aussi profiter
à nos fournisseurs
donc voilà soyons pragmatiques regardons
devant on croit à ce marché
on croit à la il faut je pense que
christiane sera d'accord là dessus il
faut continuer à recruter pour
l'agriculture française faut donner
envie pour le faire donc ça passe par
des lois ça passe par un cadre ça passe
par de moins
moi à mon avis part du transfert de
valeur et de la remontée de valeur de
l'aval vers l'amont ça j'ai jamais cru
mais par contre par de la valorisation
de la production par l'obligation ou le
contrat du distributeur de mieux
valoriser ce qu'a fait le producteur ça
passe par des accords de branche de
secteur nous répondons présents merci
merci sûr on va passer aux questions mes
collègues parlementaires on vous relayer
les questions qui ont été posées par nos
internautes et par nos nos militants
nous sommes dans une logique justement
qu'est-ce qui est celle qui a évoqué
aussi je sais qu'on la partage du
respect de cet acte de production et du
producteur et c'est pour ça qu'on
renvoie beaucoup sur les
interprofessions et moi je j'apprécie
parfaitement ce que tu dis qu'en te dis
qu'un problème est posé on met les
différents acteurs autour de la table
mais après il faut que la règle soit
établi qu'elles soient respectées
d'où l'intérêt effectivement du contrôle
parce que les règles fonctionnent à
quelqu'un à condition que quelqu'un se
sent à sur les appliquent bien et donc
c'est dans ce cadre là qu'on a besoin
effectivement d'avoir des contrôles
qu'ils soient renforcées mais il faut
être capable d'établir effectivement
quand on a parlé de coûts de production
parce que on a des périodes alors qu'ils
sont liés différentes situations
climatiques économiques ou hot
d'effondrement des cours et où il faut
faire en sorte que les producteurs ne
plonge pas parce qu'on sait que quand
une exploitation disparaît elle se remet
pas en marge du jour au lendemain et
c'est des années avant de qu'elle puisse
redémarrer alors sur les questions je
sais pas par qui ont commencé julien
julien dive donc fait des questions des
internautes directement non pas ok alors
moi j'ai une première question qui vient
de saint bernard dans l'ain par
jean-paul qui nous explique que la part
des dépenses alimentaires et plus
particulièrement des produits frais dans
le budget des foyers français est
considérablement diminué c'est vrai on
est autour de 10 12% aujourd'hui on
était trois fois plus il ya 40 ans
au-delà des difficultés économiques la
crise que traverse le monde agricole
aujourd'hui et elle pas liée à une
dégradation des habitudes de
consommation de nos concitoyens
il ya plusieurs crises dans la crise
d'abord il ya crise qu vide là qui a
fait perdre le marché
une grande partie de la rhf je crois que
c'est de l'ordre de 45 5 50 milliards il
ya cinquante ya cinq ou dix milliards
qui ont trouvé preneur dans la grande
distribution et notamment vis-à-vis du
drive mais la fermeture des restaurants
la fermeture des cantines c'est un sacré
coup pour dans tous les sens du terme
pour pour le travail productif et pour
les personnes qui sont derrière donc là
on peut pas parler de crise c'est une
crise d'urgence moi je pense que là faut
aligner faut se retrouver
je comprends pas moi je ne veux pas
polémiquer je personnalise pas mais je
serai ministre de l'agriculture je sais
ma priorité c'est déjà de regarder les
gens qui sont le plus impacté on regarde
dans les deux ans la ceux qui vont
tomber ou qui vont devoir s'agenouiller
et puis on sollicite tout le monde c'est
ça c'est une urgence après sur les
habitudes de consommation pendant la
crise là vous c'est vrai qu'il ya eu la
période tout le monde se précipite sur
le patte sur le pq et tout ça mais ça
c'est la peur panique qui fait
d'ailleurs que beaucoup de choses sont
restées en stock chez les gens peut-être
pas le pq mais le les pattes et donc ce
que je constate c'est que quand même la
crise en afrique nous a fait renouer
avec le dialogue avec le pardon avec la
ligne positive et très valorisante des
ogm est qu'aujourd'hui la crise
sanitaire est venu rajouter la
préoccupation sanitaire et
environnementale à cette demande
qualitative il faut toujours se méfier
de la statistique parce que c'est des
rapports de production je pense que le
dans la part du budget des ménages
l'alimentaire va continuer à décroître
mais mais pour autant c'est un volume en
croissance ccc faut pas confondre et la
part de valeur va s'en trouver aussi
augmenté je crois à ça d'ailleurs tous
les distributeurs investissent beaucoup
encore sur le renouvellement de leur
offre alimentaire qu'il soit à marques
de distributeurs
que ce soit dans la qualité des magasins
nous investissons beaucoup beaucoup le
cloud investi 1 milliard aujourd'hui
pour renouveler nos points de vente
c'est pas parce qu'on croit à la baisse
du chiffre d'affaires c'est parce qu'on
croit qu effectivement le bien manger
comme dirait serge papin le le le
bien-être passe par une la consommation
alimentaire ne va pas baisser
qu'est ce que je voulais dire les têtes
on va laisser passer les questions mais
pour moi donc pour moi vous voyez il ya
une sorte de confusion qui s'est
instaurée et je pense que c'est le
planning politique qu'il a ou
législatifs qui l'a instaurée
je trouve qu'il ya une très bonne
initiative qui a été prise c'est des ogm
j'en ai pas mesuré moi-même l'importance
au moment où je le commentait on n'a pas
toujours été invité à toutes les
réunions il y avait des polémiques mais
laissez moi vous dire aujourd'hui ma
conviction que les ogm ont créé en
france
les états généraux de l'alimentation de
l'alimentation il y avait des ateliers
mais l'esprit des ogm
c'était l'idée de créer une narration
collectives auxquelles pouvaient se
rattacher le producteur de saint pol de
léon
le viticulteur le restaurateur que ce
soit mcdo ou que ce soit un trois
étoiles guy savoura voilà et chaque
commerçant pouvait se rattacher à cet
argumentaire collectif qui permettait
une justification de l'augmentation de
valeur
c'était à la fois un argumentaire auquel
on peut se rattacher pour expliquer que
les pros meilleurs produits ont un prix
forcément un peu plus élevé sans que moi
j'ai en tant que discounter à me renier
c'est ce qu'on a fait avec l'histoire de
la viticulture française
la viticulture française était
dépendante du cours du vin quand j'étais
jeune et quand je suis rentré en les
entre leclerc aujourd'hui il ya plus de
cotation de cours du vin dans le journal
sud-ouest ou l'indépendante perpignan
donc les ogm permettent et ont fait plus
de vins d'entrée de gamme et aujourd'hui
même les coteaux de buzet son haute
qualité environnementale
chacun donc ça ça permet aux producteurs
d'asseoir un argumentaire sur son
évolution qualitative pour justifier de
l'évolution qualitative
il génère derrière des rémunérations au
départ c'est des marchés de niche au fur
et à mesure qu'on avance et c'est quand
même que trois ans quatre ans là ça va
très vite regardez nos publicités entre
le bio entre le local entre le label
entre toutes les allégations mais
regardez la différence entre le lait de
montagne aujourd'hui et le lait de
montagne à 10 ans c'est à dire qu'ils
ont décollé sont sortis du marché et il
ya soit une certification soit un
argumentaire qui fait que tout
commerçant aujourd'hui tout restaurateur
justifie du montant de sa prestation ou
du prix et du producteur qui se
retranche derrière ça sans avoir en se
raccrochant à une narration collective
il n'est pas coupable de l'augmentation
du prix
on est dans un phénomène général et là
dessus et donc ça part et ça augmente et
ça écarte les prix au début c'est
marginal est de plus en plus ça augmente
mais on a voulu traiter aussi par la loi
et galim l'augmentation du prix du mass
market sans autre argument sans autre
argumentaire et c'est là où du coup on
se retrouve avec un conflit les
producteurs de races à viande veulent à
juste titre ou ont un argument pour
obtenir plus de prix ou essayer d'avoir
plus de prix de la part du consommateur
du distributeur ou à l'industriel qui va
le transformer mais de l'autre côté si
on augmente dans la même proportion le
mass market l'écart de prix ne se ne se
voit plus donc ce qui fait penser que
aujourd'hui il nous faut travailler
moins sur ce qui est issue des états
généraux de l'alimentation qui va
fonctionner je suis convaincu de sa
entendez le et on va essayer l'intérêt
du commerçant de les accrocher à sa lui
même on a intérêt à vendre plus de
produits à valeur ajoutée que de
produits basiques
par contre le problème maintenant c'est
la régulation de ski et le mass market
et dans le mass market
il ya trois volets aujourd'hui dans la
production plus banalisée il ya trois
volets il ya faire plus de
transformation ça c'est très important
mais aussi pour que le producteur en
profite
qu'il soit actionnaire ou qu'ils
touchent le revenu de cette
transformation
ça c'est un vrai sujet c'est pourquoi
est-ce que tel actionnaire de gagne de
danone sur un même produit gagne trois
fois moins même si aujourd'hui c'est
discuter gagne trois fois moins qu'à un
exploitant dans une coopérative cc ou
d'un groupement je ne vise pas
particulièrement les coopératives dont
je suis mais c'est c'est là où on voit
qu'il ya un vrai travail qui n'est pas
simplement un travail de transparence
qui a un travail d'organisation qui
entravent de productivité le deuxième
sujet c'est c'est d'aller chercher
d'autres marchés
c'est un défaut de règles de mettre des
quotas ou de réguler par l'amont il faut
aller chercher d'autres marchés sur
laval et puis le 3 et d'un on est très
dépendant des accords commerciaux
internationaux
et puis le troisième volet c'est la
régulation moi j'ai entendu eux aussi et
entend le christian moi je pense que je
suis pas un ultralibéral et donc je vois
bien que par ayons tous les grands
marchés de l'énergie où tous les grands
marchés de matières premières
aujourd'hui sont des marchés régulés
ils sont soit des marchés de monopole
soit comme l'opep des marchés régulés
par quelques pays et c'est donc et pas
d'état d'âme
si le marché ne rémunère pas son homme
ou sa femme il faut réguler et donc
cette régulation elle peut être
interprofessionnelle elle peut être par
l'état elle peut être par des organismes
constitué est en tout cas je suis je
voudrais qu'on l'entende leclerc n'est
pas un noeud jusqu'au boutiste si il
faut aujourd'hui parce que les coûts de
production ne sont pas assez intégrés
décrété ou travailler au fait
qu'aujourd'hui il ya des effets de seuil
il y est je crois vous l'avez évoqué
tout à l'heure s'il faut mettre un seuil
je suis pas moi je suis pour moi je suis
pour je suis évidemment pour que
l'agriculteur tire profit de son métier
il ya des moments où il gagne pas
d'argent parce que c'est de sa faute il
est mal orienté il n'a pas pris la bonne
production
il fait pas ce qu'il faut mais mais dans
les trois quarts des cas c'est parce que
son marché
et toi êtes à vau l'eau et donc eh bien
il faut le réguler une certaine manière
et les la création de seuils
j'ose pas dire de prix médian au bureau
de lidl avait avait dit à un moment
donné et christiane m'avait un petit peu
rembarré aussi sur le sujet mais moi j'y
crois je crois que que ce soit pendant
la crise que ce soit pendant une période
transitoire ou même qu'on le décident
collectivement ensemble on peut créer
des seuil en dessous duquel un prix
considéré comme non rémunérateur
c'est-à-dire adversaires du bien-être
social et bien que ce prix soit décrétée
jésus on va on a d'autres je vais juste
pour manger la question de l'agglo
jean-paul qui fait que j'ai une question
qui me taraude et qui fait sens et
agrégation de notre internaute vous êtes
les différences et des accords sur la
question de négociation vous êtes
quelque part alliez vous n'êtes même pas
quelque part vous être lié
intrinsèquement la grande distribution
puisque 75% l'a rappelé question et
christiane tout à l'heure des ménages
vont en grande distribution
ce ne sont pas les circuits courts qui
sont vos concurrents pour autant il y a
quelqu'un dont on ne parle pas du tout à
l'heure qui est tapi dans l'ombre qui
vous observent qui n'est pas votre
concurrent qui est presque un prédateur
il vous a déjà vidé vos rayons
quincaillerie et vous avez dévoré lyon
hi-fi vous aviez pas mal de rayon ce
sont les plateformes numériques
et puisque la question notre internaute
parle des habitudes de consommation et
les plateformes numériques
elles sont pas organisant centrale
d'achat tout cas pas aujourd'hui sur la
question alimentaire comment appréhendez
vous demain ou peut-être que si mais en
france je n'ai pas le sentiment enfin en
tout cas on n'entend pas parler tant que
ça mais il ya une vraie menace qui est
là qui là pour vous mais qui il finit
hélas pour nos agriculteurs pour nos
paysans
comment vous appréhendez cette émergence
d des plateformes numériques alors
c'est compliqué de partir dans tous les
sens parce qu'on fini par noyer le
problème je pense que après avoir en
france nourrit un discours anti hyper on
est en train de discours dont carrefour
était le symbole maintenant on soutient
on se met tous d'accord pour faire faire
feu sur amazon ça résout pas le problème
ça résout pas le problème
ouais ça résout pas le problème quand
bien même il ya de la discrimination
fiscale des distorsions de concurrence
c'est là entre nous c'est pas le sujet
regardez pendant cette période de
confinement finalement on s'en est pas
mal tiré quand même vous voyez c'est il
y aura de la casse dans le secteur de la
restauration etc
mais la filière elle-même on s'en est
pas mal tiré parce qu'on ses coordonnées
on s'est parlé
nos interprofessions on parle et on a eu
un ministre aussi qui nous a obligés de
répondre
l'autoritarisme de supposées de bruno le
maire a été un facteur
quand même de coordination faut faut le
dire et donc c'est cet esprit là que moi
j'aimerais bien qu'on retrouve demain
qu'on soit plate forme qu'on soit hyper
conçoit circuit court construit à
biocoop etc
moi je pense que c'est possible pour ça
je vous dis le lait pas fun d'abord ils
sont des centrales d'achat c'est tout le
monde aura des centrales d'achat nos
fournisseurs ont des centrales d'achat
autrefois il existait un indice des prix
grand acheteur je sais pas si ça existe
toujours mais nestlé nestlé ne fait pas
son marché à landerneau enfin cesser
sinon je l'invite mais c'est ça peut
être pas mal pour landerneau mais est-ce
que ce que je veux dire par là c'est que
qu'on est des exigences sur le
fonctionnement des centrales d'achat là
je parle en tant que citoyens parlent
même pas michel edouard leclerc qu'on
est des exigences sur les comportements
qu'on est des exigences en termes de
parts de marché qu'on détermine des
seuils
moi ça me choque pas ça ne veut pas ça a
toujours été le cas et ça doit évoluer
je jeu propre à mais je crois qu'il faut
que tu prennes ton micro quand on avait
plusieurs centrales d'achat on n'était
pas réduit à 4 aujourd'hui qui font
presque 25% du marché du lait d'abord on
achète jeu en normandie le centre
leclerc du neubourg il achète pas ils
passent pas par la centrale d'achats des
centres leclerc pour acheter sa viande
pour acheter ces limousines ou pour htc
c'est l'écouté
c'est marrant parce que vous voyez c'est
un débat que j'aimerais bien avoir le
prêt avec le président de la république
parce que sur le salon de l'agriculture
ils avaient le choix d'aller chez
intermarché netto qui est quand même le
distributeur le plus investi dans la
production agroalimentaire et en
bretagne en tout cas dans l'ouest ça
pèse beaucoup
voyez je parle pas de nous je parle d'un
ter et le président est allé dans le sur
le stand de lidl donc pour moi le lidl
c'est un concurrent
c'est d'ailleurs extraordinaire la
mutation de cette boîte qui parle qui
passe du hard discount et qui changent
de modèle mais c'est quand même vous
voyez l'idole c'est quand même le groupe
intégré qui est une des plus grosses
centrales d'achat européennes qui doit
peser 110 ou 120 milliards je sais plus
monsieur mangin mais c'est quelque chose
comme ça donc en france on le voit tout
petit mais c'est sa centrale d'achat net
en allemagne et mais le président il va
pas chez intermarché
il va chez chez lidl donc ça dit quoi de
l'attitude des pouvoirs publics sur les
centrales d'achat moi moi je pense que
ce soit des industriels que ce soit les
coopératives où que ce soit les
distributeurs on va tout savoir des
centrales d'achat
parce que c'est c'est celui qui n'en
sera pas il achètera pas bien et je
parle même pas de prix je parle d'avoir
les bonnes marques d'avoir les gammes
d'avoir la possibilité
les centrales d'achat faut les réguler
mais faut pas en faire un fantasme et
qu'elle s'appelle amazon ou autres par
contre
par contre la production devra
s'organiser
la production doit s'organiser sur le
bio elle est beaucoup trop atomisées le
prix le surprit du bio ne vient pas de
surcroît peut-être il vient un peu de
surpoids de marge de deux circuits de
distribution qui sont un peu trop
sélectif qui se retranchèrent la
sélectivité
mais c'est d'abord le coût de la
collecte le coût de l'organisation qui
fait que ça coûte donc là il ya un
travail au niveau de la production
il ya des gains de productivité il ya
des des gains de coût je sais pas si ça
se dit qu'ils doivent être trouvées et
puis il faut que les producteurs
s'organisent pour faire face aux
centrales d'achat
à partir du moment où elles vont exister
à partir du mans où elles sont
nécessaires
à partir du moment où nos propres
fournisseurs sont organisées aussi pour
leurs achats
là c'est pardon du message mais le bout
de chemin il est affaire de l'amont vers
l'aval
il est il est à être organisée de cette
manière là et on peut les aider et
notamment je pense que je connais pas
assez le mécanisme répartiteurs des
subventions ou des aides mais je pense
qu'il faut je pense que enfin je sais
pas quel est le volet qui est accordée à
ça et de prix de seuil
moi je suis assez prudent voyez dessus
parce que c'est pas par d'esprit
administrés qu'on règle les choses le
temps où le gouvernement fixé le prix de
la baguette je pense que personne n'a
envie de revenir c'est pas comme ça que
ça marche
en revanche il faut que dans un cadre
interprofessionnel on puisse tenir
compte des différents aléas auxquels les
agriculteurs sont confrontés c'est pour
ça que nous renvoie sur
l'interprofession disant là il ya un
coût de production et il ya des éléments
à prendre en compte est donc avec
quelque chose qui peut fluctuer et donc
c'est là-dessus qu'il faut que les
règles soient soient tenus ça
sous-entend d'ailleurs une autre
question sur la concurrence par exemple
sur nos les produits sur les produits
d'importation sont là évoqué par
ailleurs taxe carbone etc
mais sur les produits hors saison où il
faut à chaque fois que l'on puisse
respecter les saisons que des produits
d'importation ne viennent pas en
concurrence des produits de nos
producteurs locaux ou européens si on
veut prendre la roue mais tu vois moi le
le sujet on n'est pas dans une logique
dany serait selon moi je n'y crois pas
un instant mais je crois en revanche au
fait que l'on puisse prendre en compte
le coût de production est là on a besoin
de le faire en partenariat
il faut que ça relais parce que si à ce
moment là la grande distribution ont dit
non nous on est obligé de tenir nos prix
et on va continuer à baisser les prix et
peu importe la crise et bien c'est comme
ça que ça casse alors et judas alors je
suis même si ça se passe comme ça je
suis d'accord pour faire le chemin vers
ce que christian vient de dire d'accord
parce que tout mais d'abord quand tu dis
non à l'administration ça peut être une
auto administration je veux dire si
c'est l'interprofession qui le d'accord
ça fonctionne voilà enfin c'est quoi
enfin c'est ce que je voulais dire c'est
l'interprofession peut fixer des choses
la loi doit dire le cadre légal dans
lequel les interprofessions fonctionne
mais à l'intérieur des interprofessions
il faut qu'on nous laisse quand on n'est
pas des on n'est pas des enfants il faut
qu'on nous laisse aussi nous auto
régulée on peut pas nous demander de
nous auto régulée et en même temps de ne
pas nous fixer ce cadre là je veux dire
par là que l'année dernière par exemple
le prix du porc
les fournisseurs ont demandé à
l'ensemble des distributeurs deux fois
des hausses d'accord donc il a été donné
dès des hausses après qu'elle soit
judicieuse pas assez
mais c'est le principe jeudi le principe
est donc la personne ne parle des coups
tout le monde prend sa mise
on essaye de prendre sa mise là le cours
s'effondrent et donc les industriels qui
se sont approvisionnés un cours plus bas
aujourd'hui ben demande des baisses de
prix correspondant aux baisses de cours
on voit bien il ya une contradiction
enfin on a on peut pas invoquer le bon
dieu dans tous les cas de figure donc
pour moi donc dans la loi et galim je
trouve bien l'idée de contrats
pluriannuels je trouve bien l'idée on
trouve pas beaucoup d'industriels pour
les signer de contrat tripartite leclerc
et pour des contrats pluriannuels
aujourd'hui près de 20 % des contrats
signés par la marque repère
de leclerc cds contrats pluriannuels
avec dossier avec bonduelle etc
deuxièmement des contrats tripartites
c'est plus compliqué 3 c'est plus
compliqué et des indicateurs dont des
indicateurs de coûts dont il faut se
mettre d'accord sur le plan de
l'interprofession pour que tout le monde
applique parce qu'après si tout le monde
a le même repères ça ne me gêne pas même
dans mon système concurrentiel
ce qui compte j'insiste c'est pas de
vendre le puits le plus bas du plus bas
c'est que dans la concurrence qui est la
mienne en tant que distributeur je me
retrouve pas coincé d'un d'un avantage
que j'aurais donné que l'autre n'aurait
pas donné donc si l'interprofession
on est sûr mais il faut un micro
peut-être pour nom mais c'est parce que
c'est poursuivra oui c'est ça la
difficulté
donc si christian g alim que vous avez
dit approuver dans son esprit et je
pense qu'on est nombreux à dire ça a été
une reconsidération de la production et
le bon partage de la valeur
il a été dit qu'il fallait faire des
contrats tripartites ça serait l'idéal
il y en a plus qu'il y en a eu les
interprofessions ont défini les
indicateurs de coûts de production donc
il existe on sait aujourd'hui que par
exemple pour la production laitière on a
défini ses 403 pour 403 euros tonne pour
qu'un agriculteur et 2 smic
quelqu'un qui travaille samedis
dimanches et jours de faire tous les
jours pour traire ses vaches c'est pas
trop et après on a recalculé le prix
conforme regarde avec différentes
valorisation du lycée technique mais
aujourd'hui on l'est on sait que c'est
398 euros tonne qu'il faut en viande
bovine aussi il ya eu des indicateurs
qui ont été fixés donc ce que vous
souhaitez est possible aujourd'hui les
nôtres difficulté c'est que
malheureusement il ya la loi
alimentation qui prévoit la construction
du prix en marche avant mais il ya
encore la loi modernisation d'économie
elle émeut qui elle prévoit la
négociabilité de tous et au même moment
y compris les
les promos les services coopération
machin etc
il ya une contradiction aujourd'hui
entre l'alimentation qui veut la
construction du prix en marche avant et
en plus ça correspond ce qu'il faut pour
garder la production agricole en france
sinon la perdra et les négociations qui
se passe encore avec des éléments de la
lme qui ne tirent vers le bas
donc cette contradiction faut la régler
mais moi ce que j'entends avec
satisfaction c'est que vous voulez
indicateur de coût et que vous êtes très
les respectez moi je peux vous dire à la
fin de la séquence sur quels produits on
a besoin en urgence d'arriver à payer au
prix coûts de production et donc fais à
miyako républicain qu'on peut arriver à
ça tu vois c'est pour ça qu'il fallait
venir ici mais alors oui chez les oies
rejet aussi à tanger aurait fait la bête
politique
ah ouais je suis d'accord qu'aujourd'hui
non mais je pense que je parle je pense
comme beaucoup de français le politique
aujourd'hui qui doit nous représenter
doit nous fédérer donc battez-vous au
meilleur de vos idées les gars pour les
filles pour pour recoller les morceaux
de la société française c'est
actuellement la société est complètement
fracturée ça a commencé les vtc contre
les taxis après c'est moi je suis pas
pour une conque je suis pour la lutte
contre les monopoles les concentrations
etc
mais je suis pas pour la boxe permanente
d'accord et même si on nous la tribu je
ne le suis pas d'accord et donc
aujourd'hui un enjeu politique c'est de
refédérer l'ensemble des professionnels
que nous sommes comme nous l'avons été
pendant la période de confinement au nom
de l'intérêt général et des personnes
qui sont derrière nous nos métiers il
faut nous fédérer et alors j insiste
là-dessus les centres leclerc ne sont
pas opposés à la loi et galim sur cette
partie notamment le seul truc qui nous a
donné des boutons c'est l'augmentation
du seuil de revente à perte sur les
produits non agricoles
alors là excusez nous mais vous avez
quand même pas été très nombreux
à venir acquiescer aux l'idée que le
fait qu'on augmente le prix du coca du
joker de l'evian et du nutella de 10%
salé ruisselé dans les campagnes quand
même là un tour de passe-passe fait
aussi votre autocritique là on va faire
une dernière question d'un auditeur puis
après on accueille philippe mangin qui
pose
valérie anne hallé laurent battut donne
le micro
merci la banda micro pour eux oui alors
une question justement pour conclure un
peu sur les la rémunération des
agriculteurs
c'est jacques de soisy à soisy sur seine
qui nous demande michel edouard à vos
yeux comment doit se définir donc le
juste prix de la rémunération des
agriculteurs
alors le moi je crois pas cette notion
du juste prix parce que c'est une notion
purement subjective autant pour le pas
plus pour le consommateur que le trafic
a sonné kwal juste salaire il ya
toujours quelqu'un dans le petit coup de
moins cher à côté et on le gagne et
c'est évident que à part peut-être
quelques happy few dont je fais partie
la question du revenu n'est jamais juste
d'accord et toute façon elle est pas
juste par rapport au travail qu'on donne
donc je ne crois pas trop à cette notion
morale et moral du marché mais il faut
faire fonctionner le marché pour qu'au
moins après on est des coudes
il ya des comportements brome il faut
faire fort donné aux marchés de la
capacité de générer des revenus
et c'est là où alors c'est pas on peut
faire par la loi moi je n'insiste là
dessus il faut renouer avec la pratique
interprofessionnelle quand un commerçant
quand un industriel un producteur se
retrouve en prison après dans le même
tgv ou dans le même temps au même stade
de foot je vous assure qu'on va finir
par s'entendre et c'est ça qu'il faut
recréer ne mettez pas tous sur la loi ou
en tout cas donné à la loi le pouvoir ou
le devoir de nous organiser
tout à fait et merci on compte sur vous
d'ailleurs justement pour pour le faire
vous l'avez dit tout à l'heure et tant
mieux je vais très bref christian tout
travail doit être rémunéré le travail
des agriculteurs doit être rémunéré à sa
juste valeur voilà vous l'avez lits sont
vos mots à vous l'avez dit tout à
l'heure
merci et en même temps
le l'agriculteur est un entrepreneur et
donc autant quand il ya crise et comme
l'état intervient pour le chômage
partiel etc
il faut aider cet entrepreneur au même
titre qu'on ait des salariés parce que
là c'est plus le statut qu'on aide c'est
c'est la survie autant après
l'entreprise agricole doit aussi trouver
son modèle
et comme il n'ya pas alors l'une des
choses importantes c'est de rappeler
qu'il ya pas un modèle agricole
ça c'est très important arrêter de
parler d'un seul modèle y compris moi
enfin on parle trop du modèle
alimentaire français il ya il ya les
objets acquis qui montent sont montés
tout le monde en qualité il ya plusieurs
manières d'y arriver
ensuite on s'adresse pas aux mêmes
marchés tout le temps il ya des marchés
à plus fort pouvoir d'achat il ya des
marchés de consommation culturellement
différentes infos les investir peut-être
avec des pratiques différentes
et puis surtout surtout je crois c'est
que personne aujourd'hui pas même un
grand distributeur entend des mois ne
peut fermer les yeux sur son
environnement immédiat
et justement l'impact social de la crise
sanitaire mais aussi de la crise
économique et surtout de l'ouverture
démarche induite par l'ouverture des
marchés sur le plan international
donc là bâtissons des alliances ensemble
nos fédérations ou localement mais même
enfin vous voyez je je je pensais à ça
quand le président entre up baragouinait
beaucoup là pour dire qu'il allait
doubler les taxes ou triplé les taxes
des vins français en rétorsion de g et
mes collaborateurs et les adhérents qui
sont ici avec moi pourrais vous dire que
j'ai commencé à leur dire
on attend ici nous pompe comme ça nos
viticulteurs
on va on va organiser une riposte mêmes
on va offrir aux politiques d'anticiper
cette riposte on va leur annoncer le
boycott de coca cola ou de toute autre
production américaine et puisqu'il en
est au rapport de force on va le faire
aussi comme ça mais après il ya un homme
politique pas très loin de toi qui m'a
dit mais michel
la résultante de cette agressivité sur
les produits viticoles résulte de choix
politiques faits par deux gouvernements
successifs d'avoir choisi airbus le plus
et en sacrifiant les représailles sur
l'agriculture donc vous voyez qu'on a un
aussi un sujet de fond qui est peut-être
d'apprendre à travailler ensemble toute
la filière agroalimentaire pour exiger
aussi de nos représentants politiques
dans les négociations internationales
que nos intérêts soient mieux défendus
et je pense qu'il sera mieux défendus
avec une distribution capable aussi de
riposte est de vous apporter aussi des
ripostes de ce type
j'ai juste oui juste pour terminer et
pour reprendre ce que tu viens de dire
les accords sont font partie des
propositions que nous faisons pour avoir
des accords plus juste il n'en reste pas
moins vrai que ce que nous constatons
aujourd'hui c'est que l'agriculture est
soumise à une concurrence qui est
parfois déloyale par des produits
importés qui ne correspondent pas aux
normes qui sont imposés chez nous et qui
font parfois disparaître des filières
est ce que le groupe leclerc est prêt à
supprimer de ses rayons
la totalité des produits qui ne
correspondent pas à nos normes que je
quantifie là aussi dans un rapport aux
alentours de 25% de nos importations
est ce que c'est quelque chose qui
pourra être mise en place de façon à ce
que ça donne plus de chance à quelque
chose qui paraît totalement équitable
c'est-à-dire une production française
alors bien que je sois breton je
soutiens la production française est
donc d'abord observe que dans la période
présente personne n'importe beaucoup de
produits sains c'est alors je sais bien
qu'on n'est pas dans les productions
saisonnière printanière encore et encore
dans les légumes bon en tout cas en tout
cas tout notre lait aujourd'hui il est
français ou on va dire il ya 1 2% en
tête du côté de la belgique qui se
baladent et voilà sur le port je pense
qu'on est total français
chez leclerc non à après le jambon herta
que je vends le jambon fleury michon que
je vends
ben a demandé le ses marques mais moi je
suis je
je ne le classe est prêt est en train de
s'investir de plus en plus activement
pour re francisé l'ensemble des gammes
et d'ailleurs je vous fais remarquer que
ces deux se fait qu'on avait diminué
aussi la présence de la marque premier
prix écho plus un peu le même
cheminement que aldi et lidl qui avaient
diminué de cette pression avec la crise
du pouvoir d'achat faut quand même faire
gaffe
est-ce qu'on soit pas renvoyé dos à dos
les uns et les autres aient boudé sur
nos marchés donc il nous faut quand même
des gammes premier prix donc peut-être
mettons-les dans les 25 % marginaux mais
pour le reste oui oui nous voulons
valoriser la production france est
désolé christiane si avec quelques
erreurs d'étiquetage
j'ai vu un chemillé dans un centre
leclerc mais vend c'est une erreur
d'ailleurs il y avait des deux
étiquettes dessus sur le salvador voilà
bon d'essayer mais c'est vrai que fo est
obsessionnelle pour le faire devant chez
toi ça c'est sûr donc mille pardons
merci merci à michel edouard leclerc
merci de à la fois son ton analyse
analyse que tu nous a livré sans
situation notre agriculture de notre
alimentation et puis 2,7 prêter à ces
questions réponses